do anything and you guys want to live in
a world where there's going to be no
consequences but I'm telling you
something they are consequences
particularly when you have young men
like it's it's see a lot of women so we
speak about things so you you spoke you
said I always speak about single mothers
and the reason why I do is because it's
because we have a lot of stats for
single parent homes or what they produce
and upbrings of it it doesn't mean oh
it's never always never all it's
majority man up but it's never all so
some people be raised by a single mother
and they were going to be amazing
they're going to be like Marcus rashford
and feed the kids but for every Marcus
rashford on the estate there's loads of
people that are not going to make it out
to be Marcus rashford so all I'm trying
to say is sometimes when we speak as
well you take it so literally it's not
always all there's not always all that's
all it is